So the answer is the third choice. These data structures
are getting complicated enough that they're fairly hard to read. We
need to think about what components we need to represent
the hashtable. And the main component we need is a way
of representing a bucket. So, here's the picture of our
hash table. What we want is a list, this is going to
be the list where each element in the list is
a bucket. And what a bucket is, is a list itself
where each element in that list is a key and
a value. In our case, the key is the word,
the value is a list of URLs. So the structure
that corresponds to that most closely is this one where
we have a list. Each inner list here, so this
corresponds to a bucket. And then within the bucket, a
word and a list of URLs is one entry. This
corresponds to what the entries were in our previous index
but now because we want to make it a
hash table, we're going to collect them in buckets.
So list of those entries and each element
in the outer list corresponds to one bucket.